Let's add one final scale to
our line creation toolbox.
Let's figure out how we can go from
two points to the equation of a line.
So, let's say we had two points.
The first point is at
the coordinates (1,8) and
the second is at coordinates (3,12).
And let's say, I want to write
the equation of this line, and
I want to write it in slope
intercept form, y equals mx plus b.
Which means I need to find m and
I need to find b.
M I can get using the slope
equation we learned about earlier.
And this is that equation.
M equals y2- y1 over x2- x1.
Which in this case y2 would be the y
coordinate 0.2 which is 12- y1
which is the y coordinate 0.1 which is 8
divided by x2 which is
three minus x1 which is 1.
This gives me four over two or two.
So I know the slope of my line.
To get the y intercept,
we can use the point slope form
just like we did last time.
So remember, we want to write
the equation of this line.
And we're going to do it
in point slope form so
that we can eventually get to y=mx+b.
So can you help me fill
in the blanks here?
Enter your values for y1,
m and x1 in these blanks.